a vicious bloodthirsty take on a classic
villain thrilling new twists on iconic
scenes and more Vulcans and you can
shake a phaser at here's all the Easter
eggs you might have missed in the first
season of Star Trek strange new worlds
in Star Trek Enterprise Captain Archer
has portraits of past ships named
Enterprise in his ready room in Star
Trek the Next Generation Captain Picard
has a model of his previous command the
USS Stargazer proudly on display in Star
Trek's strange new worlds there's brief
shots of at least two Starships on
display in the ready room of Captain
Christopher Pike predecessor to James T
Kirk we get our first good look of them
in the episode Ghost of Illyria when
number one is forced to take command of
the ship contemplating the crisis she
and the crew find themselves in she
stares at the briefing screen and we get
a shot that gives us a clear view of the
images of two Starships the image on the
right is a dead ringer for the nx01
Enterprise seen in Star Trek Enterprise
which has been confirmed by production
designer Timothy peel meanwhile the one
on the left shares you a mistakable
silhouettes of a Daedalus class starship
mentioned numerous times throughout Star
Trek history but this isn't just any
Daedalus class peel took to social media
to reveal that this is the USS Essex the
Starship at the heart of the 1991 the
Next Generation episode power play in
that story Picard and his crew encounter
what appears to be a distress signal
from the Essex assumed lost some 200
years before as it turns out the ship
had crashed on a Backwater planet that
served as a penal colony and whose
prisoners were trapped in non-corporeal
form Memento Mori is a tense Thriller a
ship-based episode that sees the
Enterprise encounter a dangerous new foe
but one that won't be unfamiliar to fans
known as the gone these bipedal reptiles
were featured in the classic the
original series episode Arena we later
saw them in an episode of Star Trek
Enterprise but here in the fourth
episode of strange New World season 1
the the Gorn are more like Boogeyman and
nefarious nightmarish anime who are
ruthless violent and seemingly
Unstoppable they cannot be reasoned or
bargained with and as Lieutenant Erica
Ortega's notes no one has even seen one
so how are we supposed to take them on
this is a reference to the fact that in
the aforementions the original series
episode Arena it is suggested that
Kirk's encounter with starfleet's first
contact with the alien menace that are
notes however that this is not quite
true the truth is plenty of people have
seen the gaun
they just don't live long enough to talk
about it well we know at least one
Starship Captain who begs to differ huh
seen throughout the original Star Trek
series in the 1960s the Galileo was the
subject of its own episode The Galileo
7. in that story Spock leads a team on a
shuttle that crash lands on a hostile
Planet a shuttle is destroyed but
replaced later in the series by an
identical craft that is given the same
name in strange new worlds episode 4
Spock and laan come up with a plan to
escape the clutches of the gone ships
that are hunting them which involves
taking a shuttle that just so happens to
be the Galileo
take the Galileo
it's the first time someone has referred
to the Galileo by name since the
original series and the films though
Spock also Pilots hit a shuttle craft
with the same numerical designation as
the Galileo in episode 2 Children of the
Comet the title of episode 5 spark a
mock is a tip of the hat to the original
series and to play on the classic 1967
episode a mock time in that episode
spocks betrosed to pring rejects him and
forces him to fight Captain Kirk in a
match to the death while Spock is
overcome by what was dubbed of Blood
Fever in one of the most famous scenes
from the original series Spock and Kirk
face off in a stone arena in a fight to
the death the strange new worlds episode
spocker Marcus centers on spark and to
bring opening with a direct Recreation
of the battle between Kirk and Spark
here spark is having a nightmare where
he sees himself in the same rookie
fighting ring forced a battle for the
love of the prank but this time he's
fighting a fully human version of
himself with The Showdown representing
as human and Balkan sides and a struggle
for Supremacy
everyone knows that Captain Kirk was a
bright yellow and gold tunic and Star
Trek the Original Series however he also
wore a famous alternate green shirt with
a wrap around flap and belt with a
Starfleet Insignia seen in notable
episodes like The Trouble with Tribbles
which has become a favorite among fans
for its unique design in Spock and Mark
we get a direct non-to Kirk's green look
with Pike sporting his own alternate
lime green tunic we get a glimpse of a
star chart and spocker Mark that
features many memorable locations from
the Star Trek franchise one prominent
location is the Narendra system where a
battle between Klingons and momulans
takes place in the landmark of the Next
Generation episode yesterday's
Enterprise we also see gamma eredon and
beta lancor from Redemption along with
Klingon Homeworld Chronos rural pente
the Pino colony from Star Trek's sexy
Undiscovered Country gets a notation as
does bamath the name of a Klingon
Starship on Deep Space Nine and kitima
with a federation and Klingon will one
day meet for a peace conference also
seen as a reference to the planet heart
Toria where wolves served as a governor
and an alternate future timeline in the
Next Generation finale all good things
in Sparkle Mark we meet some Enterprise
and sins who get punished by being made
to micro clean the ship's transporter
pads this has been used as a punishment
before in Star Trek history in the Star
Trek Voyager episode learning curve two
VOC orders officer Charles to clean the
pads manually using a micro resonator
which two VOC estimates will take more
than 26 hours at one point in spocker
Mark we get a glimpse of a pad which
contains the rules to Enterprise Bingo a
game of challenges played by lower
Deckers to show off for each other one
such challenge is to sneaker tripled
into the transporter buffer a reference
to the classic fur ball from the
original series these rarely seen fan
favorite aliens first appeared in The
Trouble with Tribbles and reappeared in
a Deep Space Nine episode set during
that same Adventure they later turned up
again in a short track titled the
trouble with Edward not to mention their
appearance in the Kelvin Universe flick
Star Trek Into Darkness another item on
Enterprise Bingo medical tricorder
challenge Vulcan marsupial that's a call
back to a gag from an old episode of
Star Trek Voyager that aired back in
2000 a doctor travels to the alpha
quadrant to save the life of his creator
Dr Lewis Zimmerman upon the doctor's
arrival ziderman does whatever he can to
avoid administrations including playing
childish pranks on him like this so I
spent a full hour analyzing them and
what did I discover
he's a falcon marsupial
he reconfigured my tricorder during
Spock a mock in a conversation with
nurse Chapel Spock reveals a little bit
about his upbringing and mentions his
childhood pet Sailors named ichaya first
mentioned in the original series episode
journey to Babel ichaya is described as
a fat teddy bear with six inch Claws and
later appears on screen in yesteryear a
Star Trek the Animated Series episode
elements from that story made their way
into Canon once before in unification at
the Next Generation episode in which
Spock's father sarak mentions how spark
would often run into the mountains
during his childhood we have seen
Sailors in live action before though CGI
versions of the creatures appeared in a
key sequence in the Enterprise episode
the fort those however are wild
creatures who hunted Captain Archer and
tepal as they explored the wastelands on
Vulcan towards the end of Sparkle Mark
we see a Vulcan playing chess in a park
with other Vulcans 3D chess to be
specific appearing throughout the
original Star Trek series this is a
favorite game of Sparks especially when
played against the ship's computer it
was drawing a game of 3D chess that he
was able to identify errors in the
computer in the episode of course
Marshall a casual view of spocker Mark
might think the episode's body swapping
hijinks are pretty goofy and rely on
some newly made up piece of Vulcan law
to allow the plot to unfold but long
time trackers know that Vulcans have had
the ability to dump their souls or
katras into other bodies for a long long
time way back at the end of Star Trek 2
the Wrath of Khan Spock shifts his
kartra into Dr McCoy's body later in the
sequel Star Trek 3 The Search for Spock
Kirk takes McCoy to Vulcan where to
power oversees the return of Spock's
kartra to a newly born body from the
Genesis Planet during my benga's attempt
to return their cartridge for the
correct bodies nurse Chapel makes a very
appropriate quib as she worries about
the potential failure of the procedure
they're kind of nerve [ __ ] for this
this is a reference to the stun move
used by spark and other Vulcans
throughout Star Trek history in
spockermark Ortega's mentions a girl
that Chapel once had a romantic
encounter with on ourgelius 2. we're
calling the planet seen in the Star Trek
the Original Series episode wolf in the
fold the wolf in the fold was also a
sure leap episode although it was far
from the light-hearted affair with
spocker monk in that 1967 episode Scotty
is accused of murder while spending time
in argelius 2. after investigating Kirk
and Spock discovered many eerily similar
killings around the Galaxy they are able
to pinpoint the real killer a
non-corporeal alien entity named red
Jack who feeds off of the emotion
created by his own mass murders episode
7 the Serene Squall introduces us to a
new character a non-binary scientist
named Dr Aspen played by Big Sky actor
Jesse James Keitel we learned that
aspirin used to serve as a counselor
aboard star base 12 a location well
known to track fans who have been paying
attention over the years in the original
Star Trek series Starbase 12 was twice
mentioned in the episode's space seed
and who Mourns for Adonis later in the
Star Trek the Next Generation episode
conspiracy is a strange Occurrence at
Starbase 12 that alerts a handful of
Fleet captains to a conspiracy involving
an alien intelligence in Captain's
holiday it's said that Picard's
Enterprise underwent a minor refit at
the star base as well meanwhile the
season 5 episode power play tells us
that Starbase 12 was around more than
200 years earlier and May in fact be one
of the earliest star bases as it was
mentioned by the aliens impersonating
the crew of the USS Essex which was
originally launched in 2167. under whose
command in this sector Admiral uttan
narsu to Starbase 12. that's one point
in the Serene Squall that Dr Aspen
mentions a Vulcan Rite of kolinar
surprised that a non-vulcan would have
knowledge of this practice Spock
mentions that he has yet to undergo the
ritual himself but looks forward to it
someday as long time fans know spark
will eventually undergo the right of
culinar the purging of all emotion in
between the events of the original
series and the first film Star Trek the
motion picture in fact when we first See
Spark in the 1979 movie he's just about
to complete the ritual when he's
interrupted by a telepathic
communication from Vega and is sent on
the mission at the heart of the film
during the Serene Squall Pike hatches a
plan to spark a mutiny among the pirate
crew which is suggested he's done before
alongside number one on a previous
Mission apparently on a world called
Alpha bragafor not Alpha Braga 4.
oh yeah Alpha brega 4. if that name
rings a bell it's because it's named for
long time Star Trek producer Brannan
bragger who worked on the Next
Generation and co-created Star Trek
Voyager and Enterprise in fact it's not
even the first time that star system has
been referenced another planet Alpha
Braga 7 was noted on a computer readout
in the TNG season 7 episode inheritance
considering to pring's large role
throughout season 1 of strange new
worlds fans have also wondered about
whether we'd also get to see the
character Stan the Vulcan who to bring
would go on to marry in the TOs episode
among time well in the Serene Squall we
finally get our answer with the
appearance of Stan seeing for the first
time since that original episode in
1967. as it turns out he's the prince
colleague at the encashtan katil Vulcan
criminal Rehabilitation Center working
with Vulcan criminals who have been
driven from logic getting romantically
involved with a co-worker that's highly
logical to bring after a Time
you may find that having
is not so pleasing a thing after all
as wanting the Serene Squall is loaded
with Easter eggs and references to Trek
past but the biggest comes in the
episode's final scene which features a
return of the other son of Ambassador
sarak half-brother to spunk his name is
cyborg a character track fans never
thought they'd see again we first
learned of his existence in Star Trek 5
the final frontier where he is the
film's primary villain in that movie
cybuck leaves his followers on a mission
to find nothing less than God himself
who he believes resides on a planet at
the center of the Galaxy Star Trek has
ready reference the events of the final
frontier and Cyborg's appearance here is
the first we've heard of him in more
than 30 years fans have wondered since
discovery which starred sidebox adopted
sister Michael Burnham where the Rogue
Vulcan might be the Serene Squall gives
us our answer episode 8 the Elysian
Kingdom features a fantastic Deep Space
Nine Easter egg the episode heavily
features a fairy tale book that we learn
is called the kingdom of Elysian and as
author is none other than Benny Russell
famously Benny Russell was the name of
the character played by series star
Avery Brooks in the acclaimed episode
far beyond the stars set in the 1950s
Russell was a science fiction writer who
was forced to confront racism in a
turbulent era at the time it was
strongly suggested that Russell was
little more than a vision given to
Captain Cisco by the bajoran prophets
but there has always been some question
as to whether Russell could have been a
real person now we learn that the 20th
century author may very well have been a
real writer in the franchises storied
past the episode or those who Wonder
starts off with the Enterprise on a
mission to deliver power cells to deep
space station k-7 The Mention Of This
Federation installation should ring
quite a few bells for fans of Star Trek
as it was at the center of two of the
most beloved episodes in the franchise
K7 first appeared in the original Star
Trek episode The Trouble with Tribbles
where the furry alien menace infiltrated
the Enterprise during a routine stop the
franchise returned to K7 for the equally
the Beloved Steve Space 9 follow-up
trials and tribulations which featured
the DS9 cast going back in time to
participate in the events of the
original episode
during all those who Wonder Lan enters
Captain bike's quarters and mentioned
she's been seeing the ship's resident
head shrinker Dr Sanchez the doctor in
question is actually a very deep cut
Easter egg that goes all the way back to
the 1969 episode that which survives Dr
Sanchez is heavily mentioned in that
third season episode in fact he's
mentioned by none other than Dr ambenga
then played by actor Boca Bradshaw in
one of his two appearances on the 60s
series babanger mentions that it was Dr
Sanchez who was able to determine and
sin wire's cause of death after an
autopsy which turns out to be a kind of
cellular disruption but based on what we
know now it was seen that Sanchez was
more than a mere medical examiner aboard
the Enterprise as may have also been the
ship's resident councilor and
psychologist a subtle Easter egg can be
found in the noble sacrifice of chief
engineer Hema who's been infected with a
clutch of rapidly maturing gone eggs
knowing his time is short Hammer decides
he has only one choice to sacrifice
himself to save the rest of his crew he
explains My Sacrifice save the lives of
those I care most about
me there is no other choice
[Music]
Spock's reaction to Hammer's decision
theological conclusion
Hema even acknowledges him with a Vulcan
seleuse and the age-old wisdom of live
long and prosper though it's still many
years away in the timeline Spock 2 will
ultimately make a similar choice in Star
Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan with the ship's
Systems Failing he enters the ship's
warp drive chamber which gives him a
lethal dose of radiation as he and Kirk
knows during his last moments
the needs of the many
outweighed
[Music]
the needs of the few
now in a retroactive bit of continuity
the sacrifice in The Wrath of Khan might
even be seen in a new light as a
spiritual callback to his old friend and
the chief engineer's own Noble deed a
season finale of strange new worlds
called a quality of Mercy is itself on
giant Easter egg it's not quite a sequel
but more of a what-if style remake of
one of the most classic episodes from
the original series balance of Terror
that particular hour of Television is
notable for featuring the first
appearance and encounter with one of the
franchises most enduring batch of
Villains The romulans it asks the
question what if Captain Pike rather
than Captain Kirk had starred in that
iconic episode a quality of Mercy kicks
things off with our best look yet at the
region of federation space bordering the
Romulan Empire by way of another
detailed Star Charts there we also get
what appears to be the first clear
reference to Memory Alpha inhabited
planet that's home to the Federation
Central database and Library one of the
quadrons largest collections of
knowledge the first and last time we saw
the federation's library planet was in
the episode The Lights of zatar from the
original series that's just where things
start the rest of the episode's
references to Classic Trek could fill a
whole Library Planet itself let's dive
in equality of Mercy opens with the
Enterprise and the USS Cayuga having
arrived at Outpost 4 for a resupply and
retrofit Pike and his staff meet with
the station's Commander a character is
saw in balance of Terror even his
uniform badges are spot-on Recreation of
his original patch though his name has
changed from Simply Hansen to Hanson Al
Salah this won't be the last time you
see our Salah you'll go on to recreate
the original Hansen's death at the hand
of the romulan's dangerous disruptor
weapons even delivering much of the same
dialogue is a classic tribute following
his initial meeting with Hansen Pike
realizes that he has the opportunity to
change the future but when he starts to
try he gets a strange new visitor
himself this alternate older version of
Pike is wearing a Star Trek movie era
uniform indicating he is from at least
15 to 20 years into some alternate
future a type of uniform he wears was
first seen in the Wrath of Khan and is a
fan favorite it also hasn't been seen in
live action since a 1996 episode of Star
Trek Voyager which itself was a time
travel episode bringing the action back
to the events of Star Trek 6 the
Undiscovered Country to prove he's truly
from Pike's future he uses a Klingon
time Crystal to throw the captain
forward through time to show him just
what will happen if he tries to alter
fate as the rest of the episode unfolds
long time trackers are treated to an
incredible amount of detailed references
and Easter eggs from the past almost too
many to list and fall there's the
opening scene featuring the captain
presiding over the wedding of two crew
members there's a recreation of the
classic eye lighting that was a staple
of the original series ahura is shown
sporting a classic open colored tunic
and green earrings though in this darker
timeline she doesn't go for beehive for
the hairdo but we also see the original
Romulan bird of pray and we once again
get a stunning Revelation that romulans
are related to Vulcans along with
Spock's well-timed eyebrow rays and The
Originals iconic musical score
throughout the episode we get several
key lines of dialogue from balance of
Terror including an iconic final
exchange between the Enterprise's
Captain and the Romulan Commander
in a different reality I could have
called you friend when we meet the
episode's big guest star Captain James T
Kirk played by actor Paul Wesley he's in
the captain's chair of a ship called the
USS Farragut and Kirk's captaincy of the
Farragut is an Easter egg too in the TOs
episode Obsession we learned that Kirk
had once served aboard the USS Farragut
as a young Lieutenant under captain
garavec in this new timeline with pipe
remaining aboard the Enterprise as its
Captain it seems Kirk was elevated to
the captain of the Pharaoh girls
ongarovic's departure later as Pike
reviews Kirk's service record when he's
returned back to his present we see even
more Kirk Easter eggs there's references
to his parents George and Winona both
seen in the 2009 Star Trek film we also
see a commendation the palm leaf of
axanar Peace Mission which we learn
about in the original series episode
course Marshall and then a note of his
survival of the massacre of Tarsus IV
which is a crucial plot point from the
episode The Conscience of the king like
a balance of Terror a quality of Mercy
he gives us a rare Glimpse inside an
enemy vessel with several extended
scenes providing the Romulan point of
view of the situation aboard the Romulan
vessel the commander skulls his
sub-commander and mentions a Riemann
campaign and what a waste it was this is
a rare reference to the Romulan sub race
introduced in the 10th Star Trek feature
film The Party reviewed ambosi
overlooked Star Trek Nemesis in that
film we learned that the Romulan world
of Remus was home to a race of romulans
called riemann's who were used as slave
labor in their empire though referenced
briefly in Star Trek Enterprise not long
after the film's release their mentioned
here is the first reference to them in
nearly 20 years in the climax of the
episode Mr spark is in the bowels of the
ship attempting to repair the phaser
array communicating with the ship's
engineer Spock is forced to remind him
that they have less than two hours to
restore phaser control though we don't
see him respond a recognizable Scottish
accent answers him saying
of course this is Montgomery Scots
better known as Scotty of the original
series and his line is particularly
ironic as he eventually became famous
for being just that a miracle worker oh
lady you've got a lot to learn if you
want people to think of you as a miracle
worker in his final conversation with
his younger self the future Admiral Pike
hammers home the importance of his place
in the timeline and more specifically
the changes he shouldn't make if he
tries to change the future it will lead
to war with the romulans and devastating
life-altering injuries to Mr spark and
Spock is the key because if there is
ever to be peace with the romulans Spock
will play a vital role in this or any
other timeline the importance of Spock
to peace with the romulans is a
reference that ties together multiple
storylines across numerous Star Trek
series and films first mentioned in a
two-part the Next Generation episode
unification Spock traveled to Romulus on
a mission to help unite their Two Worlds
later in the 2009 Star Trek film It's
Made mentioned that in the prime
timeline a cataclysm threatened Romulus
and Spock worked with the romulans to
help avert the catastrophe and while he
would ultimately fail his legacy was not
forgotten more recently in an episode of
Star Trek Discovery set in the 32nd
Century historians record Spock's piece
initiatives with the romulans it is
noted that Spock's work had played a
critical role in the eventual
reunification of the Vulcan and Romulan
peoples after the destruction of Romulus
eventually Vulcans would follow Spock's
example and embrace their Romulan
cousins renaming their world Navarre the
premiere episode of strange new worlds
opens with a dramatic scene on an alien
world not unlike our own in the early
21st century as scientists and military
leaders make a startling Discovery an
advanced Starship has been spotted above
the planet we later learned that the
ship traveled to this world under the
command of una chin Riley Captain Pike's
number one but it's the name of the
Starship that offers up our first Easter
egg designated SS Archer is a clear
reference to one of starfleet's greatest
captains and the star of the 2001 series
Enterprise played by Scott Bakula Archer
was captain of the nx-01 before the
founding of the Federation and helped
shape the creation of the interplanetary
organization at the helm of Enterprise
starting in 2150 Jonathan Archer made
first contact with any number of alien
worlds during his time in the captain's
chair many of which we saw in the Four
Seasons series as such it makes sense
that a ship assigned to First Contact
missions would bear his name in the 23rd
Century it's also not the first USSR
show we've seen as another ship with the
same name was mentioned in the 10th
feature film Star Trek Nemesis released
just a year after Enterprise launched on
television interestingly the 23rd
Century version single nasal setup Bears
a resemblance to the USS Kelvin the
Starship seen at the opening of the 2009
Star Trek reboot directed by JJ Abrams
called back into service by Admiral Bob
Christopher bike finds himself in a
Starfleet uniform once again and being
varied to a space dock where the
Enterprise is waiting for him he is
taken by a young Starfleet officer
aboard a shuttlecraft that bears a
striking resemblance to the shuttle seen
on Star Trek the Original Series
reimagined and redesigned for the new
series the name of that shuttle provides
our next Easter egg calling station
control the officer announces her
arrival aboard the shuttle stamets it
doesn't take a die-hard Trekkie to know
the shuttle as a reference to Star Trek
Discovery star Anthony Rapp and his
character Paul stamets the federation's
leading Astro Mycologist but why would
Starfleet canonize him by naming a
shuttle after an active Starfleet
scientist well because technically
stamets is no longer active in this era
at the conclusion of season 2 of Star
Trek Discovery the USS Discovery must
travel into the far future to save
billions of lives from a galactic threat
due to the nature of the threat the
mission was classified and starfleets
considered the vessel la us with all
hands all officers remaining with
knowledge of these events must be
ordered never to speak a discovery it's
poor drive or her crew again
as far as anyone on strange new worlds
is concerned the entire crew is dead
including stamets it was seen that not
long after the ship's destruction star
fleets commemorated the officer by
naming one of Enterprises shuttles after
him this is an appropriate honor as it
fits the Enterprise's theme of naming it
shuttlecraft after famous scientists
with the original series featuring
shuttles named for historic thinkers
like Galileo and Einstein during the
Enterprises mission to Kylie 279 a
landing party is assembled consisting of
Captain Pike acting first officer nuni
in Singh and science officer spark in
addition to feeling like a classic TOS
era away Mission they are beamed down by
their transporter Chief who Pike refers
to as Chief Kyle just don't lose massage
[Music]
he later plays a crucial role in the
success of the mission using an
ingenious and inventive technique to
beam down a serum into Spock's eyes to
allow him to pass through a retinal
scanner on the planet's surface Eagle
lead fans will recognize that Chief Kyle
is not a new character created for this
series but one whose Origins date back
to the original Star Trek series
appearing in nearly a dozen episodes the
chief ones are named for several stories
until Spock addressed him as Kyle and
who Mourns for Adonis he later appears
in a small role in Star Trek 2 the Wrath
of Khan and even pops up briefly in the
2009 big budget reboot from JJ Abrams
the original role was played by English
actor John Winston while the rebooted
version was played by Chris Duhan son of
original Scotty actor James Duhan here
Chief Kyle is played by actor Andre day
Kim as spark briefs are Captain he pulls
up a star chart of the region providing
perhaps the episode's best Easter egg
moments worthy of a long pause the star
chart is filled with so many references
to past episodes we could write an
entire article on just a shot alone
clearly visible are Kardashian Prime and
bajor the two key Worlds at the center
of Star Trek Deep Space Nine the chart
is also littered with other familiar
worlds including Vulcan and Doria and
Trill the claystron system is not far
from Trill which makes sense as it was
the home planet of one of dax's former
lovers we also see mizar the system that
was the home of Thal and core coralai
which is where Captain Picard cured a
plague both of which are featured in The
Next Generation from TOs and Enterprise
we see places such as Sigma draconis
Talos Corydon and Sherman's planet in
addition azati Prime and de nebula from
Enterprise are depicted appropriately as
not far from Earth one particularly
important location is star wolf of 359
it's here where the Borg under the
command of locutus decimated the
Federation Fleet on its way to Earth and
where Benjamin Cisco's life was changed
forever back aboard the Enterprise after
their mission away on Kylie 279 Pike
spark and nuni and Singh speak again in
a briefing room there they discuss how
to proceed with a pre-warp culture that
is attempting to use advanced technology
copied from scans of a federation
Starship as a weapon at this moment we
learn about noonian Singh's past and the
traumatic childhood incident that shaped
her into the woman she has become you
know the corn capture my family's Colony
ship
and deposited us on one of their
planetary nurseries
as we saw earlier on a pad the incident
involved the corn a species we've seen
in live-action Star Trek only twice
before in the classic TOS episode Arena
Starfleet makes first contact with the
Gorn who have attacked the Federation
Colony on cestus 3. the Enterprise as
Captain James Kirk finds himself in a
life or death battle with a gone soldier
in one of that series most iconic
moments years later on Enterprise we'd
see the gone again though this time it
would be in the Mirror Universe where a
gone slave master named SLA is in charge
of prisoners held aboard a futuristic
Starship from a parallel reality the
defiant the premiere of strange new
worlds explains that the Gorn have
nurseries and keep human captives as
food and breeding sacks adding a
gruesome new background to the
lizard-like alien race the first episode
of strange new worlds is appropriately
centered on a first Contact mission to a
world we've never seen before Kylie 279
in the best Star Trek tradition the
story revolves around the classical
dilemma of whether or not to get
involved in the bears for more primitive
culture and society that has not yet
achieved Interstellar travel to do so
would potentially violate the prime
directive though discussed heavily in
the episode some fans may find it
curious that Pike and his crew refer to
the directive however as general order
won that's because in the original Star
Trek that's what the prime directive is
called up until about Midway through the
series when the writers reshapes the
Lexicon that shift is referenced by the
Starfleet Amaral that beats with Pike
Spock and number one at the end of the
episode who knows that the order might
need a new name thanks to Pike's
Reckless disregard of order one he says
that Starfleet is renaming it the prime
directive Pike rolls his eyes and
responds well that'll never stick this
is both an in-universe explanation for
the back and forth naming of starfleet's
highest order in the original series and
a meta reference to the inconsistencies
throughout early Star Trek history early
in the premiere episode of strange new
worlds were a team to the surprising
name drop when captain pike mentions a
Starfleet office sir names Lieutenant
Kirk it's an eye-popping moment could
the future Enterprise Captain appear in
the first episode with Pike reassembling
his staff and personally selecting
several new officers for the latest crew
rotation it seems he's asked for Kirk
specifically a Spock notes while they
walk through the Enterprise's corridors
near the end of the episode first
officer Oona chin Riley tells Pike that
Lieutenant Kirk has finally arrived on
the Enterprise and is on his way to the
bridge as requested but when the officer
walks through the doorway we see it as
not a yellow shirt to James T Kirk but a
blue shirted signs officer with a
surprisingly thick mustache bike agreed
salutenant shaking his hand and
addressing him as Samuel Kirk however
this is more than just a clever gag to
bait and switch the audience as Samuel
Kirk is a character briefly seen in an
episode of Star Trek in 1967 titled
operation annihilates in the episode
deadly parasites attack an earth Colony
on deniver causing Mass insanity and
taking many lives including that of
Captain Kirk's Brother Sam we never see
the brother of James Kirk in action but
we do get a look at his body after his
death and he's played by none other than
William Shatner who Sports a thick
Hollywood mustache it's already been
revealed that James Kirk himself is set
to appear in season two so it will be
interesting to see if his brother Sam
figures into any future stories a series
second episode Children of the Comet
begins with a log entry from Cadet uhua
she is still getting used to life aboard
the Enterprise and is about to attend a
dinner in the Captain's Quarters there
she meets the ship's new chief engineer
and andorian named Hema but Hema is no
ordinary and Dorian the normally
blue-skinned and tenored Aliens who
debuted in the original series episode
journey to Babel Hema is a subspecies of
andorian known as Ina who live on the
Frozen wastelands on andoria as seen in
the Enterprise fourth season episode
appropriately titled the inner when a
horror spots Hammer chopping vegetables
she offers to assist knowing he is
visually impaired as inara all blind
Spock points out that Hammer's other
senses compensate for his blindness to
which the Ina responds compensate
they are superior it's also mentioned
that the Eno have a form of precognition
and Spark helps demonstrate Hammer's
telepathic abilities both of these
unique abilities were showcased in the
Enterprise three-part story that
introduced a young inner woman named
Jamel and her brother Gareb who until
now were the only inar ever seen on Star
Trek in that story the romulans
kidnapped garib and used his abilities
of pilot a deadly new drone ship in an
attempt to provoke a war between
Galactic powers during his dinner with
the crew captain pike entertains with a
story from his earlier years he was
chasing down a panelist Norse again
while working a security job and fell
flat on his face after tripping over the
alien's pants fazer still in hand it's
an incident that would apparently play
at least some role in his switch to
command but it wasn't the last time a
future Enterprise Captain will tangle
with some nasty Norse against while we
haven't seen Norse kins that often this
brutish alien race made a memorable
first impression in the Next Generation
episode tapestry in that story Picard
dies and meets Q in the afterlife he
offers him a chance to go back in time
and change his past in doing so Picard
revisits a violent incident from his
early days in Starfleet while awaiting
his first orders after graduating from
Starfleet Academy Picard and two friends
have a run-in with some NASA guns who
attempt to cheat them in a game of
domjat Defending his friend from a
vicious melee Picard is impaled to the
back by one of the aliens requiring him
to have an artificial heart implanted
that he'd carry for the rest of his
Natural Life thankfully it doesn't sound
like bugs brush with NASA kins was quite
so harrowing the second episode of
strange new worlds takes the Enterprise
to the Persephone star system a planet
there is endangered by a massive Comet
that is due to strike its surface in a
world-ending events in his briefing
Spock says that the people on the planet
Are A Primitive race with no way to know
the threat they face and no way to stop
it with the people below and able to
save themselves Pike and the crew get to
work on finding a way to divert the
comet from Persephone 3 but this won't
be the last time an Enterprise crew
makes a visit to the Persephone it
originally bobbed up in a first season
episode of Star Trek the Next Generation
set nearly a century later though it
wasn't Persephone 3 the Enterprise D
visited the Persephone system briefly in
the episode Too Short a season in that
story Picard and his Enterprise crew
traveled to Persephone five the pickup a
renowned Federation negotiator elderly
Admiral Mark Jameson from there they
warped to more than 4 to oversee the
release of prisoners taken in a
terrorist hostage situation things don't
go as planned of course this revealed
that Jameson himself may be responsible
for the crisis The Fallout from another
incident he was involved in decades
before Nurse Christine Chapel and Mr
spark had a brief interaction in the
premiere episode and their encounter in
Children of the comet made it clear
there's some serious tension there at
least from Chapel's side of things as
spark La an ahura and Lieutenant samkirk
prepare to beam to the surface of the
Comet Chapel inoculates them with an
anti-radiation drug when she administers
a dose to spock she openly flirts with
the Vulcan science officer although
spark doesn't seem to notice Aurora does
however and mugs him later in the
episode sarcastically referring to
Chapel as his girlfriend I remember
Vulcan we are too honest by Nature
your girlfriend must love that huh the
Sparks are of course a direct reference
to the Original Series in which nurse
Chapel played them by series Creator
Gene roddenberry's wife Majel Barrett
showed an open attraction to spark and
even got jealous of his relationship
with to bring it was in the episode The
Naked time that Chapel professed her
love for him and in Plato's stepchildren
they even shared a kiss though in the
episode it was while they were coerced
by alien talibas and neither was
entirely comfortable with the encounter
under the influence of a love potion
Spock himself became infatuated with
chapel and the quasi-canonical Star Trek
the Animated Series episode mud's
passion where strange new worlds will
take their relationship remains to be
seen inside the alien structure on the
comet's surface The Landing party
discovers a mysterious alien egg and
able to get many readings it's up to
Uhura to decipher the inscriptions on
the egg's surface and find a way to
lower the comet's artificial shielding
if she can't the Comets will destroy
Persephone 3 a horror and wettingly
discovers how to communicate with the
egg when she begins humming an old
Kenyan folk Melody to alleviate her
anxiety as it turns out that comet's
intelligence communicates through
musical tones Die Hard trackies who are
called out in the original series ahora
had shown an aptitude for singing and
must seem doing so and more than one
occasion she was most fond of a song
called Beyond Antares which he sang in
two different episodes the conscience of
the king and the changeling later in
Children of the Comet Uhura and Spock
sing together to communicate to the
intelligence and the Star Trek fans know
this wouldn't be the last time they
perform side by side in the 1966 episode
Charlie X Spock plays a Vulcan loose
while ahora accompanies him with her
sweet voice performing a song titled o
on the Starship Enterprise as a landing
Party Works inside the comet to alter
its course Pike and the Enterprise find
themselves confronted by an alien ship
the beings aboard it refer to themselves
as the Shepherds they won Pike not to
interfere with the Comets which they
believe is a kind of divine lifebringer
this is a powerful Starship that the
Enterprise can't compete with so they're
careful not to anger them but they
cannot abandon the mission to save the
planets either when they're finally
forced into a firefight Pike issues are
commands to get them out of there
barking Escape pattern April Omega-3
this is a clear reference to Robert's
April the former Enterprise Captain who
we met in the strange new worlds
Premiere April became official canon in
an episode of Star Trek Discovery where
his name appeared on a computer screen
as part of a list of starfleet's most
decorated captains alongside Pike
Jonathan Archer Matthew Decker from the
original series episode the Doomsday
Machine and Philippa Giorgio given that
April has an escape maneuver named after
him it's no wonder he's considered one
of the best in the third episode Ghost
of Illyria the Enterprise visits an
illyrian Colony on an alien world
according to number one's log entry
which opens the episode The Colony has
been abandoned with no explanation and
they are there to discover why she also
describes illyrians as a race of people
who use genetic modifications to enhance
their capabilities and levels of
function but the illyrians are not a new
species to Star Trek having appeared
once before in a third season episode of
Enterprise titled damage that episode
took place in the midst of the seasons
zindy War Arc and saw Captain Archer
encounter an illyrian vessel while his
ship was badly damaged the illyrians
were also in distress so Archer offered
to help but he wanted a warp coil in
return the Enterprise's warp drive have
been rendered non-functional and without
a new one they would be enabled to stop
the zindy from completing their mission
to wipe out Earth denied by the
illyrians who can't afford to go without
a warp drive either the story sees
Archer grapple with a moral decision of
whether or not to steal it in order to
save billions of lives in Ghosts of
Illyria the one illyrium we do see is
identical to a human while the illyrians
in damage had a series of unusual
cranial Ridges of course given their
practice of genetic modifications it's
anyone's guess what illyrians look like
naturally
in episode 3 a landing party has sent to
the illyrian colony to investigate we
see Pike una Spock and a handful of
Enterprise officers looking for anything
that might point to why the colony was
abandoned our first clue is a massive
electrical storm on the horizon the away
team is dressed for the occasion
sporting dark gray Duty jackets over the
more colorful classic uniforms it's a
cool look but it's also an Easter egg we
saw something similar in Star Trek the
Original Series the gray Landing party
jackets appear to be a nod to the
overcoats worn by the away team in the
cage the original Pilots episode in the
cage Pike Spock and the rest of the
landing party Sports similar codes
during their away mission to a planet a
natalu system which has been
broadcasting a distress signal the
rejected Pilots episode wasn't seen in
full until it was released on VHS as
part of the 20th anniversary
celebrations in 1986 though footage from
it did appear in the original series
episode The Menagerie which flashed back
to the events of Talos IV the jacket
seen in Ghost of Illyria are a clear
callback with the design updated for the
new series offering crew members better
protection and hostile environments
chief of security laana nuni and Singh
shares a well-known last name with one
of the biggest baddies in Star Trek
history Khan nuni and Singh best known
as the Nemesis of Captain Kirk in the
film Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan this
famous villain first appeared in the
original series episode space seed
whereas revealed that he was one of the
genetically engineered Sirens who
plunged Earth into chaos a drone the
Eugenics War of the 1990s put in
suspended animation he was brought back
in the 23rd Century where he battled
Kirk in the aforementioned episode and
again in the second Star Trek film
following his first feat in Ghosts of
valyria it's revealed that laan is
indeed a descendant of Khan though it's
heavily implied that she has none of the
genetic superiority of her ancestor she
seems to Harbor at least resentment over
her Heritage having been bullied in her
youth by those who learned that she was
related to one of Earth's worst
historical Mad Men it seems that augment
was a common playground in seoult used
against her a nod to Khan a key plot
point in Ghosts of Illyria is the
federation's ban on genetic
modifications as mentioned that after
the Eugenics Wars Earth and later
Starfleet and the Federation placed a
ban on genetic engineering and so-called
augments it's also confirmed that those
who are genetically engineered or
modified in any way cannot serve in
Starfleet once again this directly
references the original series episode
space seed but it also recalls several
Star Trek Deep Space Nine episodes
involving Julian Bashir the show's
resident chief medical officer in the
episode Dr Bashir I presume is revealed
that Bashir was in fact genetically
modified as a child born with mental and
physical challenges his parents arranged
for genetic tampering turning him into a
genius and Elite athlete he's forced to
hide his true nature to maintain his
career in Starfleet but the truth is
I'm a fraud you're not a fraud
I don't care how many enhancements your
parents had done when he's discovered
he's Stratton with expulsion until his
father surrenders himself to authorities
and strikes a bargain to allow Bashir to
stay in service this parallels the story
of number one it's funny how genetic
modifications helpers everyone on edge
and ghosts of Illyria she acknowledges
that she like Bashir is in fact
genetically modified once again a
prominent Star Trek cast member must
face the consequences of their genetic
status but she doesn't need to worry a
deadly virus is sweeping through the
ship and ghosts of Illyria which is why
number one feels compelled to reveal her
genetic Origins the illyrium believes
her genetically modified blood could
provide a cure but Dr umbenga explains
that he's not allowed to use allerium
blood for medical purposes when the
doctor catches a virus and prepares
himself for Sedation he has a heart to
heart with number one regarding the
bloodban and how intolerance throughout
history has held back Medical Science in
classic Star Trek fashion they talk of
prejudice and bigotry of how fear of
those who are different has never gone
away even after humans have put aside
their differences on Earth they simply
found new neighbors on different planets
to hate he Society reaction towards a
mixing of human and Vulcan blood a
direct reference to the events of starch
track Enterprise in a two-part story
spread across the episodes demons and
Terror Prime we met a group of humans on
Earth around a century before strange
new worlds who feared the mixing of
human and Vulcan DNA they were willing
to kill to prevent the two races from
intermingling
of mankind by encouraging alien human
relations while Humanity has gotten past
that hatred by the time of strange new
worlds their shunning of illyrians
proves they still have a long way to go
during the climax of ghosts of Illyria
una amidst that she is illyrian and is
genetically modified like most of a kind
as we know she kept this secret because
of the federation's ban on genetic
modifications what fans and viewers
might not know however is that this was
already established in the Star Trek
expanded universe of novels as mentioned
in the book vulcan's Glory published in
1989. in that book written by original
series writer DC Fontana we learned that
number one's name is UNA but it's said
that this is not a real illyrian name in
the book her Heritage is no secret and
her real name is not pronounceable by
humans instead she took the name una
meaning one harmonica number one was not
meant to signify her rank as the first
officer but rather highlight the fact
that she was the best of her kind of
course this hasn't been made official
but if strange new worlds has pulled her
illyrian ancestors history into play
Anything is Possible
after the crisis aboard the ship has
been solved in Ghosts of valyria number
one arrives in the Sick Bay to confront
doctor and benga about the cause it
seems that the emergency Transporters in
the ship's Sick Bay weren't updated in
space dark at umbenga's insistence this
resulted in a malfunction that allowed
an infectious disease to get past the
system's biofilters which normally
screen out foreign toxins viruses and
dangerous bacteria number one realizes
why when she analyzes hema's diagnostic
reports of the Sick Bay Transporters Dr
umbenga is keeping someone or something
alive in the transporter buffer this is
when we learn umbenga's secret his
daughter was diagnosed with a
devastating terminal illness and he soon
realized that the only way to save her
was to keep her pattern circulating
within the transporter buffer did you
know there's no limit
and how long you can store someone's
pattern in the buffer well trekkies do
know because they've seen it before in
the Next Generation episode relics the
Enterprise D crew meets the original
Enterprises chief engineer Scotty who
did the same thing to stay alive for
more than 70 years we know Scotty and
umbenga will eventually serve together
in the years that follow this episode
perhaps Scotty learned the trick from
The Savvy physician
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]